em bé đã bị mù lòa vĩnh viễn chỉ vì mẹ mắc Sai lầm khi mà xử
trí trong cái lúc mà em bé bị ngã từ trên giường rơi xuống
hôm nay tôi có xem một cái video ở trên phở
và thấy một cái tình huống của một cái bà mẹ là
em bé nó bị mù sau khi mà mẹ
xử trí không đúng lúc mà em bé nó bị ngã xuống
hôm nay tôi sẽ lên video hướng dẫn các bà xử
trí đúng khi mà em bé nó bị ngã
từ trên Cao xuống
và thông thường các em bé của mình nó ngã suốt ý
cái giai đoạn mà chúng nó tập đi rồi chúng nó tập bò
đặc biệt là từ trên trường rơi xuống như này
là rất hay bị
nhưng mà khi nào thì mình đi viện
khi nào thì mình có thể để ở ngoài để Theo dõi
thì hôm nay mình sẽ nói hết ở trong cái video này nhá
nếu cần thiết
thì các bạn có thể lưu cái video lại và gửi Cho người thân
à để mọi người cùng cái biết cách cái xử trí đúng nha
đôi khi cả thầy cô giáo cũng rất là quan trọng
nhiều khi các cô cũng không biết đâu
rồi đầu tiên khi mà thấy em bé nó ngã xuống
cái quan trọng nhất là cái độ Cao của nó
nếu như em bé nó ngáp từ cái độ
Cao khá là Cao
và cái mặt phẳng tiếp xúc dưới đất í
nếu như nó không có cái gì lót cả
nó là cái nền đất cứng và em bé nó đập
cái phần thái dương của nó xuống
và cái phần sau gáy của nó xuống nhá
thì lúc này các bà cần phải đưa em bé đi bệnh viện luôn
thứ 2 là khi mà em bé nó vừa mới ngã xong
và nó bất tỉnh ngay sau cái cú ngã đấy
đặc biệt là cái thời gian bất tỉnh của nó trên một phút
và sau khi mà nó ngã xong 30 phút sau nó lại ngất
thì cũng phải đi khám ngay đi bệnh viện ngay nhá
rồi đến cái thứ BA là cái vết ngã cái cái
khi mà em bé nó ngã xong ấy
thì cái việc của mình
lúc mà mình nghe thấy em bé nó khóc rét lên một cái
là mình sẽ chạy vào ngay lập tức
và mình sẽ bế sốc em bé lên
đấy là một cái hành động rất Sai lầm
bởi vì sau một cái dung chấn ở trong não
có thể là nó sẽ đang
nó có những cái mạch máu nó đang nó đang rất là yếu
mà mình bế sốc lên
hoặc là cái phần cổ này này
bế sốc lên
hoặc là mình rung lắc là sẽ làm Cho cái đấy nó vỡ Ra
rất nguy hiểm
khi mà nghe thấy tiếng
em bé nó khóc
ví dụ nghe
tiếng em bé nó khóc và nó đang nằm ở dưới đất như thế này
thì cái việc đầu tiên
kể cả em bé nằm sấp hay là nằm ngửa
thì các bà cũng phải đỡ cái phần gáy cổ gáy của em bé nhá
nó là cái chỗ yếu nhất mà mình cần phải bảo vệ
dù có rối thế nào cũng phải biết là a
mình phải đỡ cái phần gáy của nó
luồn Tay vào cái phần gáy này đấy
luồn Tay vào cái phần gáy đỡ gáy em bé lên
đỡ gáy em bé lên
bế em bé lên một cách nhẹ nhàng
và Cho dù là mình có rối như thế nào đi chăng nữa
mình cũng không được lắc nhá
chỉ trấn an em bé thôi
bởi vì lúc mà nó bị ngã xong ấy
kiểu gì nó cũng khóc rất là lớn các bạn nhá
Cho dù là ngã mạnh hay là ngã nhẹ
em bé nó đều rất là hốt hoảng
và nó cần phải được cái sự chấn an của mình ấy
nó rất là cần mình chấn an ấy mình sẽ chấn an em bé
sau khi mà chấn an em bé xong
nếu như mà thấy cái vết thương ngay tại cái vị trí đấy
mình quan sát xem
nhanh hay là em bé nó bị vết thương ở chỗ nào
nếu như mà cái vết thương đấy nó không chảy máu
nó chỉ u to nên có dấu hiệu là sưng to
thì các bà sẽ chườm đá Cho em bé nhá
chườm đá nhưng mà không chườm đá trực tiếp
bởi vì chườm đá trực tiếp
nó sẽ gây bỏng lạnh
mình sẽ lấy cái khăn xô cái khăn sữa của mình ấy
sẽ bọc cái đá vào túi ni lông
xong lại bọc cái khăn sữa ở ngoài
xong mới chườm
cứ chườm liên tục như thế trong vòng 20 phút
em bé nó sẽ gạt Ra nhá đấy
nhưng mà nếu như mà trong lúc mà chườm
mà thấy em bé nó không gạt Ra
tức là cái phản xạ của nó kém
khi mà mình chườm ấy mà nó sẽ khóc và nó gạt Ra
nó không thích chuyện này đâu
nhưng vẫn cứ chườm
nhưng mà lúc mà chườm mà không thấy em bé gì
là phản xạ kém là
nếu như mà vết
thương của em bé của mình nó chảy máu rất là nhiều
thì lúc đấy nếu như có băng gạc thì tốt rồi
còn nếu không có băng gạc
các bà cứ lấy một cái khăn xô sạch
các bà áp vào cái vết thương
trong khoảng năm đến 7 phút thì nó sẽ cầm máu nhá
nếu như mà sau năm đến 7 phút mà vẫn không được cầm
không cầm được máu ấy
thì các bà cũng phải đưa đưa đi bệnh viện ngay
đấy nếu như ngoài những cái
trường hợp trên
tức là ngã không Cao quá và sau khi chấn an thì em bé
nó nín nó không chảy máu nhiều
ấy chỉ xước một tí hoặc sưng lên
nhờ nhưng mà nếu mà cái vết sưng đấy nó mà kiểu sưng
to mà lùng bùng lùng bùng ấy
là cũng phải đi bệnh viện luôn
hoặc là cái chỗ mà em bé nó VA chạm ví dụ
trong cái đầu của em bé nó VA chạm
rơi xuống nó lõm
thì cũng phải đi bệnh viện luôn
bởi vì đối với người lớn mình ví dụ mình
có một cái cú VA chạm như thế ấy
thì là cái cái sọ của mình nó sẽ nứt Ra
nhưng đối với em bé nó lõm xuống là một cái dấu hiệu
mình cần phải đi khám ngay đấy đấy
mình có thể Cho em bé ở nhà và mình Theo dõi
và mình Theo dõi trong vòng 72 tiếng
trong lúc mà mình Theo dõi ấy nếu như mà có cái dấu hiệu
như sau thì các bà cũng phải
72 tiếng đồng hồ mình Theo dõi em bé mà thấy em bé nhá
tự nhiên nó sốt lên hoặc là nó nôn
nó nôn vọt không rõ nguyên nhân
nếu như mà nó lớn hơn một chút
thì nó sẽ kêu là nó đau đầu lắm
mẹ ơi con đau đầu lắm
đấy là các bà cũng phải cần phải đưa đi khám ngay
thế rồi à khi mà nó ngủ bất thường
ngủ nhiều bất thường và khó đánh thức sau cái cú ngã đấy
lúc mà mình Theo dõi trong vòng 72 tiếng ấy
có thể là ngay sau đấy nó không SAO đâu
nhưng mà một 2 ngày sau
thì
nó ngủ nhiều bất thường và mình gọi nó không có dậy được ấy
nó kiểu gọi khó đánh thức không phải không dậy được mà là
bình thường gọi tí là nó dậy
nhưng bây giờ gọi mãi nó không dậy ấy
đấy là các bà cũng cần phải đưa đi khám của em bé
nếu như trong cái ánh mắt của em bé nó lờ đờ
nó không còn cái sự tinh nhanh nữa
cái ánh nhìn của nó kiểu cái ánh nhìn nó hơi chậm chạp
cái ánh nhìn của cái đứa nó hơi lác mắt
ánh nhìn nó không còn tinh nhanh nữa
thì các bà cũng cần phải đưa em bé đi khám
còn nếu như không có những cái dấu hiệu này sau 72 giờ thì
à nó em bé khá là ổn rồi mình không cần phải làm gì thêm
đặc biệt quan trọng là khi mà em bé nó vừa mới ngã xong
các bà phải chườm lạnh chứ đừng có bôi dầu nhá
đừng bôi dầu càng bôi dầu càng sưng
to sau những chấn thương mà nó vừa mới xong ấy
thì chườm lạnh nó sẽ làm giảm viêm và giảm sưng rất tốt
giảm đau nữa còn sau khi mà em bé nó ngã xong rồi nó tím
tím cái chỗ này nó kiểu nó bị bầm tím lại ấy
nó tụ máu ấy thì lúc này các bà mới chườm ấm nhá
các bà có thể luộc quả trứng lên hay cái gì đó
các bà chườm ấm để làm Cho cái máu ở đây nó tan Ra
nó dễ dàng được mang đi cái cái nó sẽ tan cái vết bầm Ra
còn vừa mới ngã xong
trong 6 tiếng đầu tiên thì phải chườm lạnh nha bà
và chườm lạnh đối với da của em bé nó còn rất là mỏng
nên là các bà phải bọc cái khăn xô ở bên ngoài
là vì vậy nên có những cái tấm thảm để mình giải Ra
để tránh cái việc là
à cái lực của em bé nó tiếp xúc với xuống mặt đất lúc mà nó